quelque chose d'aussi compliqué que vous pouvez
imaginer un peuple tombant d'Air
Force One et Iron Man les sauvant
finalement comment y parvenir et vos
premières approches faisons-le sur la
scène de l'écran vert, nous pouvons accrocher l'acte
car nous avons beaucoup de  contrôle mais notre
deuxième directeur d'unité est venu à bord et a
dit que je connais l'équipe de parachutisme Red Bull
, faisons un test, je ne crois pas que beaucoup de
gens pensaient que cela pouvait être fait
pratiquement et je suis comme si je savais que nous pouvions le
faire pour de vrai  En fait, j'ai eu un
tas de parachutistes qui utilisaient et nous sommes
allés à l'aéroport et avons passé deux
jours à sauter et à faire certaines
des séquences les plus difficiles, c'était
tellement réussi que nous avons dit, tournons-le de
cette façon et j'étais toujours
pensée sceptique allons-nous obtenir tous ces
clichés, nous commençons à construire des costumes personnalisés
avec des parachutes cachés Jake brake est
celui qui a fait ça, il le fait
depuis le tout premier Moonraker lorsque
James Bond a sauté de l'
avion sans parachute qu'il a dépensé  Pendant environ deux
mois à construire tous ces
parachutes cachés et à tester des jours pour le tirer,
nous avons fini par faire 62 charges d'avions
sur 600 sauts en parachute 480 quelques
sauts en parachute cachés, ce qui est de loin plus grand
que n'importe quel type de séquence comme celle-ci
n'a jamais été fait auparavant